juvenile.
Alhamdulillah.
[Silence]
inshallah before we begin with our
questions for the evening we will
begin with a
a issue as we usually do some sunnah or
direction from the prophet sallall.aii
regarding salah or adan or what have
you. Tonight's
narration
has to do with
the salah
before we begin our prayer. When we are
headed to go to the masid to make salah,
when we are headed to go to jama, what
is the proper etiquette? Our prophet
sallall.aii wasallam has said in a nar
narration collected by
al im alkari and imuslim.
He said sam
for
[Silence]
Massage it.
for
[Silence]
iman.
A very important issue a statement that
the prophet sallallahu alaihi wasallam
made in Sah Muslim. He said if the is
called
then do not come to the prayer while you
are hastening and rushing.
rather approach the prayer calmly and
while walking and upon you is
tranquility
and calmness
for whatever of the prayer you catch
then make and whatever of it you missed
then make up. So this is our first
narration. This narration the prophet
sallall.aii alaihi wasallam prohibits
prohibits
it is impermissible.
It is haram. Haram in the sense of is
it a major sin? No, this not what haram
necessarily means but it is
impermissible.
The prophet sallall.aii alaihi wasallam
prohibited that when a person come to
the salah that they come rushing,
jogging, hastening, right? Often times
when the and we see this often, but
we'll we'll circle back to this
inshallah. He says if the is called
starts, you do not come to the prayer
while you are hastening while you are
running. rather come to it while you are
walking and upon you is calmness and
tranquility. Whatever of it you miss
than make up and whatever of it you
catch then make along with the im.
He said because as long as you are
headed to prayer, you are in prayer. So
whatever is prohibited in prayer is
prohibited on your way to prayer
except for a few things speaking
for instance. It's haram to speak or eat
or drink in prayer. But he said saiam
the etiquets of prayer they apply not
only to when a person begins his salah
but also as long as he or she is headed
to the prayer and we will come back to
this point in a moment. The next
narration is the statement of the
prophet sallall.aii Wasam and Muslim
where he says if the is called then do
not stand until you see me come come
out. So in order to kind of visualize
this the prophet sallall.aii wasallam
his
rooms they had a door that connected and
would come into the masjid. When he
would come out sallallah.aii wasallam
into the masid, he would come out from
if this were the if this were his masid
right here, he would come out from this
side.
Wasam in the front, right? And he would
come out to the front row and find the
companions.
But on occasion the would be called
and he could hear it from his huja
but he wouldn't come out immediately.
Maybe he's getting dressed. Maybe he's
talking to someone. Maybe he's dealing
with something. Maybe he's in a sunnah
salah. Maybe there could be a number of
reasons. The point isn't that. The point
is that the companions
when the time would come would make the
and the people would stand up. The
prophet sallallah.aii alaihi wasallam
came out and said if the is called do
not stand meaning stand and line up for
prayer until you see me coming out until
you see me come I have come out come out
of where I'm coming from
and so this with a number of other
narrations and evidences the fah give us
a principle what is the principle
The Adam
is in the control of the muin.
The muadin controls the adan.
If the imam were to come and say make
the adan early, make it late etc. If the
adan is being made on time according to
the timing of salah
then and inshallah next week the entire
talk we will do only on aden. Inshallah
there's really so much to unpack there.
But the adan
is to the discretion of the mu.
The
is under the control of the im. The im
is the one who controls the because he
controls the prayer. Therefore he
controls when it begins and when it
ends. For this reason the adan is made
according to the discretion of the mu
but the is always made according to the
discretion of the imam.
Therefore the prophet sallall.aii
wasallam taught the companions do not
stand for prayer until you see the imam
has emerged has come out. When the imam
comes out that means that it's time for
prayer. But notice the wording that he
said here. If the is called,
if the is called, do not stand until you
see me. This means that even if the were
called and the im is not in the masid
yet, we still don't stand for salah,
right? And you know we're trying to
learn these sunnen and merge them with
our clocks because our prayers are
usually dictated by the timing correct
is the time of the salah. We agree with
each other for instance that we're going
to pray at 8:15 for instance. That's
fine. That is there's nothing the matter
with that. However, these issues of
and timing and so forth, these
moments or minutes, they are as well
dictated by the presence of the imam or
the absence of the imam. Going back to
that first issue, how many of us know
here? I think probably every single one
of us here knows
that
if you come into the masid and the imam
is in salah leading salah
at what point do you are you considered
to have missed the the whole you have to
make it up at what point
how much of the salah do you have to
miss to have been considered to have
missed the raqa. Who knows the answer to
this question? Yes. Young ruggedly
handsome man. Mhm.
[Arabic recitation]
you get up from the rur. That's a very
interesting way of saying that. I'm not
sure what that means. But you mean when
a when he rises from bour
you if it's the fourth then he's
gone up.
[Arabic recitation]
come into the masid. The imam's still in
the first.
[Arabic recitation]
when he rises from or is it when he
makes sujud or the second sujud? At what
point do I did I have to make the whole
over the whole one unit over when he
when he rises from when he rises from
everybody is in consensus. Okay,
we know this. We all know this, right?
Did you think I was going to say
something different? It's she
what what is this? This guy's is pushing
it now. He's telling us all kind of
stuff.
This is something that the have agreed
upon
because the prophet sallall.aii wasallam
has said in so many words and in a
number of narrations in different ways.
[Silence]
that if a person catches the im
then they have caught the entire raqa.
Now
here's the point where misunderstanding
occurs.
If I missed the
meaning I caught the imam in the
standing position or I caught the imam
in the sujud position.
Many people understand this to mean that
I'm not rewarded for anything I do until
I have a fresh.
And so what do people do based on this
understanding? Even if they don't say
it, this is how knowledge works. When a
person misunderstands something, it
reflects in their actions. So sometimes
a person will come to the masid, find
the imam in
sujud and they will stand in the line
and wait,
right? And wait for the im to make sujud
make sujud stand back up and then they
will start with the im.
Why are they doing this?
because this behavior is based on the
idea that if I miss the
then I'm
then you know what's the point what's
the point of making this addition
does this mean that you're not rewarded
for and standing and putting your face
on the ground and saying subh
you're still rewarded it's just it's not
counted as a full
why because You've missed more than
half. You've missed more than half of
the right.
And so the prophet sallall.aii wasallam
said and and based on this as well we
have the opposite effect. What's the
opposite effect? If the person walks in
the masjid and finds the imur
it's always the guy with the keys. It's
always the guy with the keys. I don't
know if he's a janitor or if he's a
whatever he is. He's in every masid,
right? And
all the way. Okay, we hear you buddy.
Thank you. Thank you very much. And then
what kind of salah is this? What is
this? Right. This is exactly what the
prophet sallall.aii alaihi wasallam
prohibited with the first narration we
just heard because the companions did
this. They didn't do this generally. It
happened. It's an occurrence that
happened in his time and he corrected it
when he saw it. Sai wasallam.
As a matter of fact, Abu Bakr,
not Abu Bakr, Abu Bakr.
He walked in the masid once. The
narration is ink.
He saw the prophet sallall.aii Wasamur.
He walked in the door. He went into Rur
at the door and then he walked in until
he got into the room.
And so after the prayer, the prophet
sallall.aii alaihi wasallam said to him
[Silence]
and so he said
you know he commended his diligence
but he said don't do that again so he
commended his diligence but he said
don't do it again but he also didn't say
make the make the oath it was valid it
was valid so the point here is that
because we know that if I miss the I've
missed the
the drive now comes that if I see the
imur I rush
that rushing
is not befitting of the masid or salah.
And so the prophet sallall.aii wasallam
said to the companion the companions
Fore.
[Silence]
And so he said, "If the salah has begun,
do not ever come to salah in a rush
ever."
and come to the prayer while you are
walking calmly and tranquily because
you're in prayer as long as you are
headed to prayer
and so it is impermissible
for that rush that running that I need
to catch that bour and this also stems
from a misunderstanding of what is
happening when you are speaking the
you know what what what you miss of
the prayer. It doesn't mean that you're
not rewarded for the sujud. As a matter
of fact, you're rewarded more than if
you would have just been praying the
regular prayers because you have extra
there. You have more
and each word and each letter and each
sujud and each you're going to be
rewarded for. It's just not counted as
a.
So these are two issues I mentioned to
you. Do we have any questions about that
or anything else for this evening
[Arabic recitation]
would the from his room
especially in B would come and tell him
first and then he would walk out with
him. So now the second part, do you
recommend the the to make on time or
till he sees you coming out? The mu
always makes
only when the im is in the masid unless
it's you know an understanding
between the imam and the muin right like
for instance the office here you can see
I'm in the office correct you can see
when I'm walking out when I'm
approaching that's okay however it is
best and most correct that once the
im is in the masid that is when the is
to be called and most usually by order
of the imm says now make the then the is
called now
[Arabic recitation]
seven parts of the body that touch the
ground making
[Arabic recitation]
reason I didn't is because we had a
whole about that before but the last
two parts are the
the edges of the two feet and what's
meant by the edges is the I don't
know what the physiological name of the
part of the body is but the toes would
be pointing towards the
and the part where the toes meet the
front of the foot that part would be
what is touching the ground.
At least
in sujud, a person's toes should be what
are touching the ground. There's never a
situation where a person is making sujud
on the backs of his feet. Right now,
[Arabic recitation]
What about somebody come second?
there is
a misunderstanding that happens and that
is that we know or many of us know that
the prophet sallallah.aii alaihi
wasallam said whoever prays alone
behind the line his prayer is invalid.
Now what the meaning of this narration
is if there was a place in the row
meaning a person comes to the masid
finds that the row is not full but they
see someone they don't want to stand
next to or for whatever reason they pray
behind the row on their own or they
start a new row by themselves and they
end up going through the salah alone
behind the row.
This person's prayer is invalid. He has
to remake his salah. All right? However,
if the row is completely full, there's
no space for him. What should he do in
this situation? And so, Abu Ali brings
up a good point, and that is what some
people do.
Well, let me ask you guys, what what do
you think? What have you seen happen?
I'm sure we've seen all kinds of stuff.
What do people usually do?
[Arabic recitation]
now we have two incomplete rows.
Right now, nobody wins. If I can't win,
nobody's going to win. You ever see a a
barrel with crabs in it? Right. If I
can't be in a row, nobody's going to be
in a full row. Right? There is a
narration
of that mentions as much that if a
person comes to the prayer and finds
that the row is full, they should
then he should pull someone back from
the row in front of him and stand with
him. This narration is agreed upon
as being
very weak and some judge it as Imam
Muslim does as being fabricated.
This narration is not authentic. Right.
And it's based on a narrator of
hadith who who is who is known amongst
the scholars of hadith to bear.
And so this is the wrong thing to do. As
a matter of fact, when we have something
this, a situation this where
there's no set narration
and
we have a very weak narration like
this. Okay. Maybe that weak narration in
itself is weak but its meaning is
correct with regards to the patterns
that we learn in the Quran and Sunnah.
So let's look at other situations in the
Sunnah. What is there anything similar
to this or any principle that we can
resort to in order to pull someone out
of the first row? The answer is no.
Absolutely not.
And what makes it even worse is that if
you're starting to pull someone, they
don't want to come out of the front row.
Or if you start to pull someone, they
don't know what you're doing.
Or there's many situations, right? The
person stands and makes salah.
Allah says Allah does not burden any
soul more than it has to offer, more
than it it can bear.
There's no rope. Am I supposed to create
a rope or should I not pray? No, you
pray.
incorrect as well as well. This issue of
waiting for another person.
[Silence]
for
the
And so the prophet sallallaihi wasallam
prohibited specifically
that a person even if they've already
made salah and they're in the masid and
the is called and the j is made the
first j that you should pray again. You
have to pray again if you're in the
masid. There is no situation where a
person is hanging out who is Muslim in
the masid while the Jama is going on.
Right? And so
here this is for someone who's
already prayed. How much more so for
someone who has not prayed the
obligatory prayer.
Therefore a person prays by himself.
Where do we know this from? Well, I'd
mentioned the verse to you. I mentioned
the a hadith but we can go a step
further. Is there a situation where a
woman would pray by herself behind
behind the row?
Just one woman by herself behind the
row. Does that exist?
if the brothers are in their row
and then one woman comes to make salah
and there's no other women, would she
pray by herself behind the row? No. The
prophet sallallahu alaihi wasallam said
if you pray by yourself behind the row
salah is invalid but the scholars agree
that her salah is valid. Why?
The reason she's not in a role is a
legislative excuse which is mixing
between men and women. Right? And that
is a legislative excuse. How much more
so a physical excuse. There's physically
no more room. Right? And so the point
here is that a person would never
just stand idly by and not pray. That's
one option. Another option is to pull
someone from the row ahead which now
instead of having one
one situation which is
you know not recommended. Now we have
two situations that we've taken one
problem and made them into two or the
person prays by themsel and that is what
the person does
and that is what the majority of the
Now that's a very good question though
that person should align behind the im
right he should behind you online.
[Arabic recitation]
question. Where does the roast start?
Where does the roast start? Here here's
another issue. You know, she is he he
said something really interesting
and why I mentioned this, I'm not trying
to pick on anybody. We all are born
ignorant. All of us, right? Allah tells
us
Every one of us is born purely ignorant
and then Allah teaches us knowledge is a
risk from Allah subhanahu wa ta'ala.
however
we have an issue not us here
specifically but the Muslim world and
especially in the west right and the
issue is not having the full story
having half the story this can be
particularly devastating right so a good
question here and that is where should a
person begin where should they stand
okay we at the front the row is full.
Now the person where should they stand
in relation to the iman? Now where
[Arabic recitation]
times have you come in the masid and
find people the right side of the imam
is very full and the left side is
sparse.
Especially if the door is on the right
side. Then we have a double a double
situation. I can get out the door first
and I can be on the right side of the
im. But
this is again due to a misunderstanding.
So the companions
said
other companions said
we used to prefer to be on the right
side of the prophet sallall.aii alaihi
wasallam in prayer because when he would
convey a salam at the end of the prayer
he would start with our side and he say
you start on the right side right
and there's you know
and so the issue is that we want to pray
on the right side. And is that
preferable? Well, a lot of us know that
it is preferable
because of these narrations of the
companion saying they preferred that,
right?
There's a narration that states Allah
and his angels make a salah upon the
right sides of the rose. This narration
is inauthentic. The prophet sallallahu
alaihi wasallam did not say that. And so
that is preferable. But what's the whole
story? That is only preferable
when both sides are even.
Right? So you come in the right side and
the left side are both even behind the
im.
Then the right side is more preferable
than the left. That's the only time.
There's another narration.
There's also a narration. Put the im in
the middle when you start your prayer.
That narration is inauthentic, but its
meaning is correct.
The point isn't to be on the right or
left side of the imam. The point is to
always be in the place that places you
closest to the imam. That's the sunnah.
Notice the wording that I'm using here.
And that is what puts you closest to the
im regardless of right or left side. If
the left side places you closer to the
imam than the right side, then you would
go to the left side. That is the best
place. If you are standing in the row
and the people on your sides are too far
apart for you to be connected to both of
them, which side do you go to? You go to
the side that puts you closest to the
im.
When you come to the prayer, you go to
the place that in the row that puts you
closest to the im. Because this is what
the j is. It begins with the imam and
everyone musters around the imam. Right?
And so the only time the right side
is preferable is if the right and left
are even. Now the right side is
preferable. However, the preferable
place is always the place that puts you
closest to the im. And you always begin
the row right behind the im. If the
right side was the po place you were
supposed to be on with regards to the
imam,
we could easily fix that. We could have
the imam pray over there and everybody's
on his right side.
Correct.
Problem solved. No, that is not what is
intended. What's intended when the fukah
say the right side or the companions say
the right side what they mean by that is
in the in this instance which right or
left are even which side would I choose
choose the right side right try to be on
the right side otherwise the row should
never be lopsided
where it's to the right too much of the
imam or to the left too much of the imam
Even if it is sisters praying behind a
woman imam, she would stand in the row.
She wouldn't stand in front the men
stand. The imam, the sister imam would
stand in the row, but she would still be
where? In the center. She would still be
in the center. Now, we could probably
have one more question very
quickly.
try to keep it under half an hour for
[Arabic recitation]
but it's okay. We we we should we
should you know always bring it up
you know constantly until it becomes our
culture that we know the sunnah becomes
our culture. So the chair
you have different types of people.
Some people are praying on the chair the
entire time right and then some people
only use the chair for or for instance.
And so the point
is where does the person place himself
in the standing position. That's how we
make the row straight. Not in the rur
position, not in the sudjul position, in
the standing position. So when
everybody's lined up, his chest and
torso and shoulders or her chest and
torso and shoulders should be in line
with the rope.
Even if the feet are coming out in the
front or if the person is standing and
they only use the chair for and then the
chair should be behind them and they
should be standing in the row. So the
point of making the row straight is the
torso, the shoulders, right? That is
when the when we are in the standing
position, lining ourselves up for
prayer. I place myself
in the position that makes me in line,
shoulders and chest in line and torso
with my two neighbors, male or female.
And the chair follows that never the
other way. And a person may say, well,
what about the row behind you? You know,
if the chair is sticking out in the
back, if the row is sticking out in the
back, then if it is not possible for the
row in the back to compensate, they can
start a little bit back or they can skip
that spot. or they can or it would be
good or preferable if the person had
himself in a situation where he knows
he's going to pray in a chair and it's
going to be behind him that he pray at
the very end. Right? So as not to
disrupt the row behind but we don't
we don't build our
row based on the row behind us. Right?
and say, "What about the row behind us?"
No, the row behind us, we cross that
bridge when we get to it. We straighten
each row on its own. But this issue of
not disrupting the row is important. So
for instance, sometimes people will
bring their small child to the masid and
they want the child to pray in the row
with them. The child doesn't have wudoo
is a very young kid. the kid is, you
know, too young to to be able to
distinguish or or hold an intention or
hold wudoo and they'll put the child
between themselves and the person next
to them in the row. This is not
permissible. This is impermissible to
do. The child should be at the very end
of the rope so as not to disrupt the
rope because that person there who is
not making salah or this child who
doesn't have etc is disrupting the
continuity of the row. Now the row is
disrupted. It's as if there is a spot
there and the prophet sallall.aii alaihi
wasallam said
muster together in your rows and don't
leave any spaces because I can see a
shan walking between you in your open
spaces a baby goat walking between
the rows. So the prophet sallall.aii
wasallam tells us that if there's an
open space between the people in the row
that a shan will capitalize on this
space to disrupt our prayer and disrupt
our reward. Now that is enough for
tonight. Inshallah we'll continue this
next week.
Alhamdulillah.